hey everybody and welcome to a
controversial wild ride with stevo i'm
telling you this episode has more cans
of worms than a louisiana bait shop yeah
it's wild it's crazy
and let me tell you too that i just got
a new prescription like i couldn't see
turns out i needed a new prescription
and it drives me nuts that i'm wearing
the same pair of glasses for now three
episodes in a row i mean i always loved
changing it up but you know what i love
changing up even more than my glasses my
underwear baby these me undies it's
almost endless the choices that you can
have for this great underwear that feels
so good when you wear it man i'm telling
you i love me andy's and i've got a deal
for you it's
satisfaction guaranteed they say if you
don't like it then you just give it back
and you get a full refund or an exchange
but you'd be out of your mind to want to
give these back i'm telling you and if
you go to meundies.como
then if it's your first order 15 off
baby and free shipping so what are you
wearing ugly uncomfortable underwear for
go to meundies.como
and
enjoy 15 off of your first order and
free shipping plus endless choices of a
great looking super comfortable
underwear now let's get into bobby lee
there's another guy scott yeah scott
randolph yeah he's he's my guy he's your
sidekick
yeah yeah he's on the podcast though
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's using the loo
we got we got it all dude we got [ __ ]
we got oh [ __ ] i didn't know this was
gonna happen look at this guy's face
it's one of the best
one of the best in the business right
here
bro look at that face bro
yeah dude what's up dude you're sick huh
he is
pretty [ __ ] hot he's a hot dude right
here dude what's up dude dude what's up
bro what's up dog town
[ __ ] yeah bro
we're going to [ __ ] or what bro
[Laughter]
i'm getting nervous bro
let's get your mic a little lower so we
don't obscure your beautiful face my god
this is like
i can't say i'm legit i think tiger but
when i think tiger belly do you get you
have headphones or you don't do that no
we don't need it uh do you want
headphones
we get your headphones
that's all that's all right
okay uh when i think of tiger belly i
think of pink
is that fair
pink i think
yes fair i mean pick a color yellow he
said that's what it's all about if you
want yellow pal how's that the tiger
bell is more yellow bro oh tiger belly
that's because we're asian but that's
why he's wearing a yellow beanie
[ __ ] yeah
you would have a connection huh i know
it's for real it is all right where are
you from bro
you're me and this dude right here have
a connection bro yeah that's scott
randolph man dude yeah i know you said
that before bro and that's paul briskey
paul briskey and here we go bobby dude
it's like a you got like a car please
don't do that bro
well we're gonna get there
he's like a carney methi kind of a guy
right i like it connie methi you know me
like when you go to the fair are we
rolling on all cameras here we go yeah
we sure are ladies and gentlemen
bobby lee
what's up
dude this is a long time coming huh it
is i flaked a couple of times we have
flipped
a couple a couple you flicked it
first it's a real flake fest it wasn't
that i flaked as much as i just uh
didn't respond wasn't i didn't respond
i'm very good at responding this is the
culprit when it comes to not responding
i'm the captain of it
yeah i bet your money when you were
younger bro you were some hot [ __ ] huh
me
yeah scott randolph i still am hot [ __ ]
no but you thickened and you're a little
older yeah it's still good it's still
legit like if you were in the grocery
store we wouldn't take you off the
[ __ ] shelves it's still like i'm a
staple exactly bro yeah but i'm like
cheerios
but you were more [ __ ]
20 years ago 20 15 five
five
five yeah i mean dude if we're really
gonna attack scott randolph like i'm not
attacking him i'm giving compliments
right okay
if i was a food dude like i wouldn't be
on the shelving you'd have to ask the
person that works there and they'd have
to go in the back to get me
do you mean like
it's kind of a specialty this compliment
is like if i'm going through the tsa at
the airport and the guy says oh man like
where you've been dude i haven't seen
you in anything forever
i hear when that happens dude and i'm
like dude i'm very active just on like
youtube i know i [ __ ] hate it
and because we're alcoholics yeah yeah
we're covering all garlic we said we're
sensitive to that right well he is too
so i started thinking about it like on
the plane like that happened to me at
the lax i'd be on the plane thinking
about it but is that not the backhanded
compliment that you just gave scott
i'm like i'm a model and you're like
what a hand model
no
the model citizen stop bro
bro i like that no what i was doing is
like
you know
like you remind me of a josh brolin type
yeah now or then no so josh brolin now
goodness or sicario that's what i'm
saying right so i'm saying when he was
in goonies he was too young
how about thrashing
thrashing he was in a movie called
thrashing how old was he then oh my god
perfect
right
now it's a little bit of a rugged you're
right like i feel rugged i like bro if i
was in bed with them i'd feel this
scruff against my belly
this facial scrub against my belly like
i love you bro thanks dude because you
have like a midwestern skateboarding
type of i'm from the midwest and do you
skateboard uh i used to but i broke my
whisper my wrist and i stopped yeah i
get that yeah yeah skateboard next time
anyway i wasn't hitting on you bro no
it's all good it's just we
don't remember playing ping pong at
steve's house back in the day oh that's
right
i played ping pong yeah did i win no
but you're better than i am but you for
sure lost dad i remember that night very
very well i asked you bobby to come over
and give me notes
on my
comedy act like five days before taping
the special that was ridiculous with uh
ian edwards yeah yeah and you were you
were like why did you
get us over here
like five days before taping the special
i know it was just like it's almost too
late yeah that's what i felt you were
like we can give you notes but what did
you do that in high school did you like
crazy
if you had a test that night like
midnight you started cramming
i mean i guess yeah oh i never went to
school really myself
yeah yeah where'd you grow up
in san diego bro oh really yeah where
you from bro pasadena
[ __ ] yeah dude
do you um
you know my brother that's your
brother's name steven randolph and
chelsea
wait stephen randolph your brother yeah
your real brother uh-huh oh that's right
yeah because stephen yeah that's right
you are him
yeah yeah and now i get that i get it
i know the vibe maybe that's the
connection
there's a connection there you also look
like him like by his vibe right here's
the thing steven randolph is scott's
older brother and would like to
physically abuse him like traumatically
because he was such hot [ __ ] like like
steven randolph was so not as attractive
as scott scott got all the attention and
so steven randolph took it out on him
physically violently yeah i get that
because steven randolph um he's a
physically violent guy
he's not like that
he's like a standard white
his face he's like you know he works
like he looks like he works at
enterprise
rental or you know your meat or like
he's the manager at home depot right you
have more of a like you know 70s porn
vibe
josh brolin josh yeah yeah yeah i like
that
magnum pi vibe dude yeah you like that
yeah i don't i don't no
i don't like it
but how's your girl
my girl's good man you guys are
we're
going straight we have not gotten
married yet yeah yeah because i'm so
proud of you i wear i wear a a ring out
of respect yeah because i think it's
ridiculous that the woman should
indicate she's taken and not the man
what does that say about our society
right like only the woman should wear a
ring to indicate that she's taken does
that mean that it's assumed the men
should continue to
to fornicate with others yeah you
probably get hit on a lot too
well that's the other the the the flip
side of it is that the wearing the ring
it's like chum for
sharks right
you're chumming the water
you're saying that the ring makes them
even more crazy i mean i don't know i
don't care because i
i remember having a conversation with
you
at uh what's that earth bar we were
there to get our healthy juices oh yeah
bumped into each other and i was telling
you about uh how i had trouble with
relationships and how i was uh seeking
sexual sobriety
yeah you you actually can i just i want
to be completely honest with you
out of all the human beings i've ever
met on planet earth i'm almost 50 and
two weeks i'll be 50 years old
and you are the most one of the most
fascinating people
i've ever encountered in my life i'll
tell you why because i've never seen a
human being go through such a
transformation than you
it's like you're the poster child of
like
that like 12 steps of work and you know
what i mean and all that stuff works
because it's like when i first met you
bro i thought you were like a human scab
yeah
yeah yeah you were like just this thing
you know like he would walk in the room
and we kind of
you know kind of you know oh you know
like what the [ __ ] yeah you know i mean
and it's like it was the first time we
met uh when i got kicked out of that uh
video game awards was it a video game
awards
oh boy i don't look cool in this story
because you know what i really was a
scab and i stunk too
but i don't stink anymore man because i
use the best deodorant there is it's
called native not only do i use it my
girl lux uses it too when i came home
with this stuff we both decided we like
coconut and vanilla the best and she
says no that's mine you're not allowed
to use it like whoa okay good thing i
love the eucalyptus men every bit as
much i mean there's 10 different scents
and they're all amazing they all work
incredibly well and they're all only
made from quality ingredients that you
can actually pronounce in which you know
what they are like coconut oil or shea
butter and like i said it is effective
it works and it leaves you smelling
fantastic so now how are you gonna get a
killer deal glad you asked you go to
native d e o dot com
stevo or just use the promo code stevo
at
nativedeo.com up to you man either way
you're gonna get 20 off your first order
and you're gonna get any number of these
scents and you're gonna love them all
man i'm telling you because i do so
don't be a scab dude don't stink dude go
to native
d-e-o dot com slash stevo and enjoy
twenty percent off your first order yeah
dude smell great and feel good now let's
talk about me being a
scab was the craziest
dude i remember you had to show up to to
rehearse the show you were just running
vegas right yeah it's the video games
awards right samuel jackson is hosting
and we're doing the rehearsal
right first of all i'm so i'm supposed
to present with you we're code
presenters right well we were we were
supposed to
that was the intention yeah that was the
intention right
then all of a sudden like you know you
you're a little late so i'm already
there at the where i'm supposed to be my
mark
you come in
and you start screaming at
samuel jackson
you go what are you doing that's for
you're a
and i remember being so in the audience
was because there were other presenters
in the audience it was pat oswald and
brian poussein
and i remember them looking at me and
pat oswalt looks at me and he goes with
his mouth i'm so sorry
right next thing i know they drag you
out
right and then next thing i hear is that
you're banned from the mgm
uh for life or something like that yeah
i mean
something happened backstage i don't
know what happened right but that like
that was like my first encounter with
you yeah what year would this been
uh
maybe
2007 sounds about maybe yeah and i
remember i had to present by myself
yeah i mean so now the live show you got
to present by yourself i got to present
my bible but i would have loved to do it
with you
but you were like out of your mind that
was the first time we met and then the
second time we met yeah was at the this
super high-end
fancy
massage place it's called burke williams
i don't think i was yet sober at that
point
but then to see you go from there
right to like
vegan to like you know i mean you know i
mean i'm not masturbating for next for a
year
430 days yeah i'm you know i mean i'm
sober
i live a clean life and just being like
this transformation that like just kind
of blew my mind
because you know when you get sober i
still have like
my things right like you know i i smoke
oh you do yeah i see you know i still
sometimes masturbate to porn
like in in a very like
you know alcoholic way you know oh yeah
like what there are many different
approaches to masturbating to porn what
do you mean i mean peop there there are
people like scott randolph who would put
like i went nine times in one day before
why
well i don't know how do you masturbate
alcoholically well it's like
the motto that i was raised with if a
little is good a lot's better yeah but
by the ninth time your dick must have
looked like a dog's dick like like a
licorice yeah i wasn't too worried about
that was it bleeding no i don't know i
don't really remember too much you can
come out when you like little visine
drops came out after you can and then
there's then there's other people who
just for like one for one orgasm will
spend like 10 hours that's what that's
what i do oh they said you're like i'm
about to come right and then i'll just
release right and i'll let it even go
down
yeah so you're an it's called edging is
that what it's called it's called edging
you get right to the edge right then you
back off i back off so so you'd actually
put out i mean that's like such a time
suck yeah my penis goes
and it goes
i wonder if that's good for you like i
think it's it i don't think it's good
it's not good there's nothing good about
it there's nothing good your heart is
right yeah
when i went to the therapist he was like
do you masturbate like in two minutes or
do you like take you ten hours and i was
like oh like two minutes and i was like
yeah got it and he wrote a note but i'll
tell you why it's not good
it's because
you know i went to
i went to a place because my when my dad
died
you know what i mean all this
ish all these issues came up because my
dad used to beat the [ __ ] out of me
growing up and all this trauma came up
and i couldn't eat or sleep i relapsed i
relapsed you know i have two years
almost now but a couple years ago i
relapsed and i um
i couldn't eat or sleep for months i
lost like 40 pounds i was on the i was
on that i was gonna kill myself right so
then i went to a therapist
and we talked about my upbringing and
the trauma so then i went to a place in
arizona right so when i was in arizona i
signed a contract because it's like they
said you not only you know i got sober
but they they're like um
when you masturbate the porn because i
have trauma you have to understand that
people that are in porn also
went through trauma and it's just like a
cycle of like
um so the place in arizona the general
path no i went to a place called
p
s
c or something like that
but anyway but anyway
you know when you that's why i haven't
been to strip clubs either because it's
like it's just like these
women are just you know i mean they just
had
i'm not saying all of them but like you
know a lot of them have gone through
tremendous amounts of trauma and this
and that it's just not a healthy yeah
well
you know but i still sometimes
masturbate when uh this is so when you
had the relapse it was just with weed
i gotta say there is a lot that i love
about bobby lee but the way that he's so
open so honest and candid and
transparent man i respect that he
reminds me of my whoop app which openly
honestly tells me everything that is
going on with my health and fitness
starting first thing in the morning by
telling me what my recovery is and thus
how i should approach my day now i'm
every bit as transparent as bobby lee is
so i don't mind telling you that i only
got 37 recovery today what does that
mean it means i might want to kind of
take it easy it's not the time to go on
a marathon right now maybe rest a little
better drink a little more water and
then just attack tomorrow yeah that's
important stuff to know man if you want
to be in good health for a long time you
should have a whoop band which you get
absolutely for free and you can use this
app which gives you so much insight by
going to
whoop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
com
and when you get to woop.com you use the
promo code stevo and that gives you 15
off at checkout and you're off to the
races man with all this insight into
what's going on with your body with your
health with your recovery with your
fitness and man it's the way to live a
better life so one more time go to
woop.com use the promo code stevo for 15
off at checkout now let's talk about
that relapse
yeah it was hard though man because it
was like well the first week was great
because i had 17 years of sobriety
right imagine 17 years
and then it's like when i got when i was
sober the last time that's when the weed
starts stores you would drive by the
weed stores and go what's that like but
then i was able to do it
right and because i have a little money
too right i was i went to every weed
store
in la and i would go to the high-end
place like the high-end section to [ __ ]
with this
you know mexican wheat i want to go to
the most expensive weed and i bought
everything
so i had like
probably ten thousand dollars worth of
weed
stashed in my house
like literally in [ __ ] black you know
you're with your same girl the whole
time yeah but i hid it from her for
about
a month
i was able to hide it you're smoking
in in the beginning it was oils
that's when i was able to hide it oils
gummies and those types of things drinks
because they sell drinks did you
overdose or not overdose but did you
like have like panic attacks from like
eating too many gummies ever
i would i had something a medical thing
that i'd never even went to the doctor
about but one time i was taking so many
gummies that i froze
in my living room where i could i'm not
kidding you i couldn't move
and then my body felt like i was in ice
like i was frozen and i couldn't move
and i was shaking and because i was i'm
not being i'm being i had a similar
experience one time when i drank
aluminum cleaner
really i swear i drank aluminum cleaner
when someone told me it was like a way
to get high what is aluminum cleaner and
i was paralyzed on the the kitchen floor
and this shitty little apartment i
rented and i i couldn't even like reach
my phone to call for help i know it
wasn't this terrible maybe the same
thing happened but like i remember going
to the finally making to the bed and
putting all the covers on and just
shaking so then when then my girlfriend
i finally confessed that i relapsed
and then she's like what are we gonna do
like i can't live with somebody and i go
well i'll go to this i'll go i'll go
somewhere eventually but just give me a
month
wow so she let me smoke pot for a month
in my house my new at the time was a new
house so i just remember just like
this is when i know i was an alcoholic
and drug addict because i would wake up
at like nine in the morning
go in the backyard
smoke 9am
to midnight
i wonder if it's great
yeah
it was great i mean it sounds great i i
almost started saying it's not offensive
to ask this question but then i remember
what you said to scott randolph when we
started so
go ahead like is it fair to say like
you're you're a girl i'm a girl no no
you're you're you're a girl
like is it fair to say that like how did
you get her
how'd i get her yeah
right right now i'm picturing her saying
like i can't be with someone and i can't
be with you if you relapse and then it's
like when you say that's how you know
you're an alcoholic like well when
you're when you're you and you're with
her and like this is a deal breaker for
her you'd like you'd think you would get
sober in two seconds no yeah yeah yeah
yeah no i i i i was willing but at that
time at the time it was like
i saw death
around the corner for me yeah
and i was like
i'd rather i want to die i felt like
dying so because the past trauma was
coming because my dad died and like i
was just like lost and
you know i mean i couldn't eat or so it
was terri even in fact your brother so i
went on the road and your brother and
his wife opened for me yeah in portland
and this is how bad it got they they
they were the ones that first ratted me
out
good
so they were the ones that called my
girlfriend and said i think he's using
because i was hiding it from them too
but they could tell because you know
they're both sober yeah yeah so we went
to the sushi restaurant and i hadn't
eaten in three days i'm not kidding you
and you know what i want to try to eat
sushi i ate half of this i vomited the
sushi up but weren't you smoking weed
didn't that you did it no it doesn't
because
when you have the kind of trauma that i
do it trauma affects the body
right like trauma if you don't deal with
it and release it if you especially had
a difficult childhood that [ __ ] turns
into cancers and strokes and all kinds
of stuff right
and then you got to go through this
process of relieving it through emdr and
some other techniques and stuff right
but it's like i um no i it was weird i
could not eat
i couldn't sleep
i would be just i would take six gummies
smoke you know and all that stuff and i
would lay in bed and i would not sleep
all night
just in my head you know i mean and
and the the the thing that like
the main memory i had as a kid
was um
when i was like eight years old
my brother steve and i used to sleep in
the same room
and i remember like it was four in the
morning
and the lights turn on in my in my
bedroom
and my mom isn't in the room right
and she's crying and she's like
panicking and she goes
in korean she goes help me
help me block the
door you know
so me and my brother we're kids we're
blocking the door and i remember my my
mom opened her mouth and her tooth was
missing
and she was bleeding
like my dad
punched her in the face
and then we're like i could hear my dad
you know trying to open the door and my
brother and i and my mom were just
[ __ ] clinging onto this door and they
finally got out and i don't even
remember what happened that's not even
in my memory so probably something
horrific happened
right that i couldn't even you know
but let's get that's how and
i was raised
with just a rage-a-holic
that was like and i you know
being a small sensitive kid
you know i resorted to drugs and alcohol
and humor
as a defense mechanism and also
you know just not trying in school and
acting out and all that stuff right
that's the way i
dealt with it and it was a miracle
that i found comedy
because i honestly believe if there was
if i didn't do stand-up when i was 23
years old
that's something god i mean god awful
would have happened i think i don't
think i would have i would have had a
great life
what's the age difference between you
and your brother three years
that's the same with my brother is he
younger older younger and
he was also cuter than me
so you used to in high school i never
got any [ __ ]
i was unfuckable
and um i still think i'm unfuckable
but um my brother always got girls
he was cute but i never beat a mob for
it like your brother did
[Applause]
two things now he beat the [ __ ] out of
you
you ratted me out this [ __ ] no yeah yeah
yeah he he's one of the best guys now i
still i still love him i still love
steven randolph but he definitely beat
him up because he was better looking
yeah
he is a talented guy
he's very talented he's a super talented
guy i love him i do too i i genuinely i
genuinely love stephen you guys got to
say something nice about him he's going
to be really excited i know because he's
going to beat me if you guys don't say
something nice about him nobody i mean
dude like when you were little kids
yeah i know dude we we got over it you
know
he had a natural reaction to being
jealous of your of your better looks
he's a little kid you know like there's
nothing in there and and he cared about
bobby you know like was he supposed to
keep secrets and then bobby's dead and
then what was he supposed to think like
when it comes to addiction and
alcoholism you have to rat on people
otherwise they're going to end up dead
and it's going to be your fault so in
both cases he did the right thing i
think he did i don't think if he was
sober he would have done the right thing
because he's a sober guy he did the
right thing yeah for sure and um your
brother has is very much like me because
when he stresses out
i relate to his stress like sometimes
when he used to work at the comedy store
i would see him just like have his hands
on his head and he'd just be like you're
me stressed out about some deal or you
mean some opportunity that's like
you know i mean going away and he would
just completely just get consumed by
something yeah and i'm like that you
mean so i relate to your brother in that
way as well okay yeah yeah
are you like him
depends on what
probably are you sober yeah i got eight
years oh congratulations so you both is
this youtube
and my sister my sister's totally normal
why is she older middle middle i'm three
years younger it's like uh three years
apart one two three oh wow yeah yeah so
um
it skipped her mm-hmm
i heard and i'm not gonna say who i
heard it from but that but that like
when you're on tour
yeah that when bobby lee's on tour
that despite the fact that you do so
many shows on tour that you're like
gripped with anxiety before you get on
stage like every single time yeah that
doesn't go away no
no i heard like um
and i thought was i was something wrong
with me but then it's like
i heard meryl streep not meryl streep um
barbra streisand
before every show she vomits like in a
you know me yeah you know me gets so
nervous dude i'm not even a stand-up
steve makes me open for him
i check my heart rate before i go up
it's 170. yeah
it's you know i'll be honest with you
it's not something and it's it's
annoying what i do
i'll tell you why because um
and whitney cummings right confronted me
on it
because one time i was at the comedy
store and i was being really anxious
right
pretending to be anxious
right and then i went up i killed and
then afterwards
it wasn't good and she just pulled me
aside and she goes i'm done with this
she confronted me she's like it's a show
what you're doing is bull it's like
you know you're
we're not going to buy into
this charade that you're you know i mean
like do you do you know you do well and
then you get off and you just want
validation so before so before my set i
go through this thing that's so annoying
where i don't really feel
anxious i know what i'm doing i'm gonna
crush i'm going to do well right but i
go through the emotions like you know
it's so you know i mean oh the pressure
and all this all the stuff and then
afterwards i could kill it doesn't
matter afterwards i'll always go i
wasn't that good you know what i mean
and it's like my openers will be like
didn't have to just deal with it right
but someone like whitney you know i mean
is my luck she's probably a bigger level
than i am and she's just like um
stop and so since she did that i don't
do it anymore good i don't go through
that process because it doesn't it's
it's annoying like
like
so i sit like i'm going to show you so i
sit like this
right yeah see the way i'm sitting cross
leg yeah but this is not my natural way
of sitting my natural way of sitting
is like this
right this is not it
right but so do you know this banned
hot snakes
i don't know how cause there was a band
called drive like jehu
anyway the lead singer when i used to
work at a coffee shop all right
this is before i did stand up i worked
at the panic and coffee shop in la jolla
one time i saw the lead singer this is
in the early 90s rick farr
come to my coffee shop he was wearing
one shoe the other shoe was missing
right and i knew that he was a lead
singer one of my favorite bands drive
like jehovah right
he was sitting there like this drinking
a coffee right like this
and i remember
practicing to sit like him
because it's not my natural way right
like forcing my little legs to like do
this you know what i mean and then like
just act act kind of like an artist
almost this is so gross what i'm saying
right and so it's like
from then on like i just pretend to be
this thing like this artist guy this is
so annoying that i'm what i because i'm
i'm i want to change right so i think it
all stems from rick farr
this guy this guy you know what i mean
i'm still thrown off by that crazy slur
you just used
which one
the g word on yourself
yeah my little g
legs g money likes what i say
we can't say it i can't i wouldn't care
we can't we can't
what are you saying what did i say paul
what did he say i don't remember
i heard it you remember it well okay so
i said
okay
that's probably gonna demonetize this
whole podcast right that one word do you
think so heavyweight can you beep it
yeah yeah
we could beep it yeah we can beep it was
a heavy word yeah
all the time do you ever get in trouble
for that on youtube
well i i think that if a black guy says
the n word it's okay right right
demonetization
man said the m word
and uh that was a problem yeah it's a
problem yeah yeah but i think that as an
asian person i can say
the g word yeah no no no we meant some m
m word
yeah you said it with the m right i
think can you say that like you say ook
with a g
that's probably fine it's fine it's
probably fine i'll see if i can do that
right but i'm just saying that um
so he said egypt right but he is an
idiot so why can't he say that
right that was and that was actually the
point he was making while he said it he
was telling a story right about it
getting cut out of jackass too when he
was the one who said it and he was like
i'm the one who said it oh god it got
cut out and it got our but i remember it
maybe who cares but but yeah it was yeah
you know it's
um i want to say something and i i want
to be it's a sensitive time yeah it's
not only a sensitive time but um
i have to
i think when it comes to comedy
right
this is
i think we're going to be in a very
scary territory if we start completely
editing everything that we're saying
i mean especially in comedy in comedy
and i and i um
i struggle with it because it's like you
know
everything that i say on podcasts and
radio shows and stuff
are number one
pretty much lies
number two they are pretty much live
exaggerated stories
i'm wild i say wild things you know and
um
you know that's always been since
after mad tv i was always kind of like
of a shock
kind of a shock comic you know i mean
saying crazy things and stuff like that
and showing your wiener yeah yeah i used
to i may not show the actual wiener but
i would go dance in my underwear or
whatever right and be provocative in
that way and i just you know it's
there's a freedom to that i live in
america you know i mean i am this little
asian guy you know i mean i wanna you
know i mean i want to express myself you
know
and um
we're just in a really scary time man
because it's like
you know we have to watch everything we
say stuff that i've said before like 20
years ago or coming back around and
people are going will you say have you
gotten in trouble
i don't want to talk about it but i have
you know i mean and it's like those
things that i'm in trouble for
are complete and utter
lies and exaggeration they're jokes and
you know they
and i feel bad i guess i you know i mean
there's a part of me that feels bad but
it's like
you know at the end of the day it's like
my core being is i've never really done
anything to harm anybody or
you know i've done anything i've always
been sober guy i've always been you know
my little brief moments of relapse but
it's like i um
i know it sounds like your relapse looks
more like you in fetal position than out
there being hateful oh yeah yeah no i
don't i never yeah i mean i wouldn't go
to even do a comedy club and smoke pot
with the comics i would be
just in my i'm like that kind of
alcoholic you're not yelling at samuel l
jackson at them yeah
yeah
but do you when that happened though
i've always wanted to wonder when you're
when you're there
at that event and you're getting kicked
out what are you thinking
um it's so funny because your
perspective was probably like dude i
went and showed up and like dude they
didn't need me and i just left cool
well i mean i think there was a there
was a
level of embarrassment that i had yet to
be clear
but
the overwhelming sense was that oh cool
now i don't have to even worry about
doing this show i can go straight to the
to wherever i can find cocaine oh
wow you remember that that's that scene
i i totally remember that scene yeah
yeah yeah and um
you know i was just like okay cool man i
don't have to wait to like really let my
hair down yeah
yeah even though it was pretty well down
already i remember like i remember
they're like what's most shocking about
that day was that i made it through the
airport and and and i was allowed on an
airplane and then like
because i was screaming and i was
screaming and
going through the airport oh my god i
forget what my deal was that i was
screaming
but uh yeah i was i was was that before
or after the smoking on the airplane ah
the smoking on the airplane was ages ago
yeah you smoke you lit a cigarette on an
airplane yeah my philosophy was
that
whenever you get on the airplane they
say this is a non-smoking flight and
federal law prohibits tampering with the
smoke detector in the bathroom
they don't say federal law prohibits
smoking
this is a non-smoking flight and you
can't take they never actually you know
yeah so i'm like okay so it's so federal
law does not prohibit me from tampering
with the cigarette in my seat
it's like i didn't go in the bathtub i
didn't even i didn't even say i didn't
even go in the bathroom
with the smoked attacker because i'm a
good guy yeah i stayed in my seat and
tampered with a cigarette wow so give me
the misdemeanor because i already know
it's not a federal official what
happened
turned out that it is a
federal offense to uh to disregard the
uh instructions of a flight attendant
yeah and uh and and and then he said i
need you to put that cigarette out yeah
and so i i i stepped i jammed it into my
wrist and and twisted it around and
and uh burned burned uh
my wrist and then then i lit up another
one after he walked away yeah and then
he came back and said come on man yes we
please really nice please yeah yeah and
and then and then uh that was when i
started hurling slurs at him
were you in the air
were you in the air at this point um
yeah
we found the footage recently i watched
it and you're also like this is gonna be
great wait just wait watch i'll just
watch like like he was gonna be amazed
once you lit it and like so did people
come on board to take you out or you
would
we were already in the air yeah when the
plane landed yeah the uh the the law
enforcement uh
people
came on everyone to stay in their seat
and they extracted me first
you got priority
[Laughter]
uh yeah i think probably from l.a so
smoke for five hours the whole way there
in the plane no but if i recall
correctly we connected in atlanta
meaning it was a delta flight [ __ ] you
do have what i have which is like um
and i don't have it as a sober guy but
sometimes i have this thing where it's
like the rules don't apply to me
either i mean like driving rules or just
different rules i have this thing where
it's like it just
you know
like if i get a parking ticket on my
in my car right i'll literally just keep
it there
until the natural winds blow it away
wow it's crazy i don't pay it and then
what happens what it just i i deal with
the consequences later
you mean whereas like my car will get
towed so you get a ticket on your car
what goes on in your head like [ __ ]
these people i don't even think about it
i just keep it there i've had two of
them on there before
i want to clarify that i did not hurl
even back then this was 2004. i did not
hurl racial slurs
and i was i was just like uh i mean that
doesn't even really help
yeah
i i i was
back then i was like uh to me if i
wanted to be insulting towards someone
yeah i would say agath
i don't know if that guy i'm not saying
who knows yeah yeah it was just general
i was just trying to be generally like
uh
derogatory you know it didn't even have
anything to do with
with that with anything about the guy i
miss white people like what happened to
you guys what happened to us why people
have become so sensitive and like i
missed old white people
like asian like
like like gran torino yeah like i like
you know i grew up i grew up with such a
hostile like
racism what about uh even
what about that story i saw in tmz about
tony hinchcliffe didn't he speak up
about it like at the time
so uh so what when you mean the opener
yeah when is when he called the eye
opener
there's something like in and out
to be fair i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
be completely honest with you
okay
and asia is going to be so mad at me for
this
but
like one time this gay comic brought me
up on stage
he's a friend of mine right
so i called it i i go one more time for
the agate
right
and he goes [ __ ] you you know to me you
flat-faced was he pissed or was he no
we're doing
comedy you know i mean
you [ __ ] fat or whatever and then i'm
like
[ __ ] you you know and we're like we're
killing right
like the audience is by eating it up
it's like a rapport that we have right
it's like
you know um we have the relationship
this kid is his opener right
and it's like the things that i've said
about my openers have been crazy
you know i mean like insane right but
it's like they were it was never taped
right and i think that um it's tony's
audience right
he
asked this kid to over open for him
right there's a rapport that there's
sort of like this unsaid rule that like
you know
in in that environment it's safe
to [ __ ] make fun of each other this
and that and i understood kind of what
tony was doing you know i mean it's like
you know
would he do it to me
no
because if he did i would do it back to
him right like i i i could have said 10
things that would have made him cry
because i just know personal things
about him you know what i mean but it's
like you know
to me when i saw that at first i was
like oh that's kind of [ __ ] up right
but then when i actually thought about
it i was just like
it's it's a
yeah i mean
it's it's kind of
tony hinchcliffe is a is a master
comic he's a great really really good
yeah and he's got that kind of
sort of like dry like you know
like almost like jail neck almost like
we're like offensive yeah dry yeah
defensive and so it wasn't like too far
out of his
style of comedy you know it was a little
bit on the nose like not not not as uh
it's provocative it's edgy people
laughed nervously you know i mean but
it's like
it's also kind of like i could see in
the moment like i'm punk rock
you don't mean i'm edgy you know i mean
this is
against
the culture right now you know and it's
like you know i understand all that but
you know is tony hinchcliffe in his
heart a racist no
you know i mean was he just
doing his brand of comedy yeah yeah and
i think that um i agree
i do i mean i really do and being like
there was that other kid i forgot his
name shane gillis
yeah on the saturday night live yeah i
got fired from saturday night got fired
from that i guess james got hired he
didn't even get to do a show no he got
hired and then he didn't even do a show
yet and then having him on tiger bill in
a couple weeks
and um it's just another thing it's like
he said it on a podcast
right and as a comedian i think anything
goes
for me you know i mean it's like
you know you say crazy things i've said
so many crazy things right and it's like
some of them aren't cool you know me
with today's culture and today's you
know
how this it shifted you know it shifted
on us the world
you know and it's like
um i know i was just like you know
also as an asian guy at first when i saw
it i was a little offended like tony's
you're my first initial reaction but i
have to think about
i mean
who he is
what the environment is you know i mean
and um
what his heart says you know did you
shoot him a text
no at the in the beginning no because i
don't know him
you mean changing us no tony tony no
i never texted him
because um
i thought i didn't think it was that big
of a deal until later i don't know
he has
moved on he survived it it wasn't like
anything
like uh yeah what about ari shafir like
what's going on with him lately what do
you mean
i remember when he like did his his kobe
joke
that was not good for him
and and i wonder if that's
example of what i'm going to say is that
he's on brand
yeah and um
i thought i personally thought it was
poor timing
you know i mean
i personally thought that it was um
just
unsavory it's not not cool right you
mean it you can't
you gotta leave some time
he didn't do that he did it immediately
yeah yeah i mean and so it was just all
and it wasn't yeah it was that was a
tough one that was a tough one but still
at the end of the day it's like
he's doing what he does
that's his style
right and it's like
if you don't like it don't follow him
yeah right i found out kobe died from
ari's post
that's funny you know i found out about
9 11 the day at 9 12.
yeah i found out about it at 4 00 p.m
that day
what you weren't loaded no no i was
super sick
and i just didn't pick up the phone i
just slept all day yes and the next day
i went to a starbucks and it felt weird
in there
right and then i looked you know at
starbucks just as like newspapers and i
just saw the twin towers exploding
twilight zone yeah yeah and then i i
remember picking it up going what the
[ __ ] right and it's like i was just a
day late it was weird
man can i tell you that
one of my favorite jokes and it was on
twitter and it was about someone being
dead the day that they
died like no time was yeah it was so
[ __ ] funny who was it okay i don't
know the name of the person but it was
on tmz
that i get my news from tmz and the
story was that a magician
committed suicide by hanging themselves
in a closet
at the the magic castle they were found
dead
and and jeff ross
copied the link to this tmz article
right and tweeted it with one word what
he wrote
abracadabra
yeah that is so [ __ ] funny it's very
funny
did you get in trouble for it no yeah
yeah i mean this is a long time ago this
was uh let me go back to arie ari is um
he's in new york
and it feels i feel like he's doing all
the clubs and he's everything's fine
another thing we have to also understand
is just you know i mean the new cycles
it shifts so quickly
right 24 hours 24 hours and even with
just come in with comedians and stuff
it's like it shifts so what he did is he
went
to peru he went somewhere
for like six months after the kobe stuff
and he went to thailand he went all over
the world and traveled and
he hiked you know and he came back
and um
it seems like it it died when he got
back so now he's just
doing his own thing i i don't really
read anything about
ari you know
but can we talk about
kate quigley
sure
you know who she is i'm not sure uh do
you know who she is okay is this funny
kate yeah i saw a red band post saying
hey give her some love you don't know
what it is yeah she was in this overdose
party
in venice
yeah dude this is gnarly i never i don't
know about this at all
right is a very funny comedian
girl
um i used to hang out with her
she's a nice girl
and she was
i guess at a party with three other guys
in venice
and they
snorted some cocaine
that was laced with fentanyl mm-hmm i
just saw that headline three guys died
[ __ ] and she was in the icu this weekend
but it looks like she's gonna make it
oh it's like that
what do you mean she was like
we thought that her organs were gonna
shut down and she was in a coma and she
was gonna die
you know i mean but now now in this
situation do they know
that the cocaine is it like that like a
perk it's like oh dude i got some killer
coke and it's got fentanyl no i think
they just i think some cocaine just has
fentanyl cut into it i don't know i it's
not my drug you know i mean it's not my
scene and also i'm sober so i don't know
much about it i mean that's the real
when i relapsed two years ago was just
like i'm not doing opiates i'm not doing
these things because it's like i still
had obligations i still had a career to
somehow
figure out you know i mean i was on a
show at the time so i was just like
you know i i just weed
my gut just said just stick with the
weed
yeah i mean because it's jesus dude is
weed any different now and then is it
obviously way [ __ ] strong i didn't
smoke for i didn't i hadn't smoked weed
at that time for 17 years so even
probably like the worst kind of weed
possible you know that you could get
from mexico or whatever yeah would have
been you know i mean insane but for me i
went to like the high-end [ __ ] you know
with the the purple little
you know i mean little
hairs on it you know
and i just remember getting
so
high like i went to hawaii to shoot
magnum and i was high and i had a day
off and it's done some weed and i was
just like
walking down the street
and just crying laughing about i don't
remember what it was
but i just remember like i had to pull
my side
right and i was like by myself like a
sad guy you know what i mean and just
you know laughing so [ __ ] much right
but then like after
a couple of months of doing it
you it just becomes super
and you know in your heart you just go
this is not going to end well this is
not the life i want to live i want to
live um
i want to live in the light
you know what i mean it's cool yeah so
what's what's what's new for you you
turn 50
you're gonna get married yeah i mean
this last year has been the best of my
career
it's been insane i did a movie in um
hungary
with kate blanchett wow jamie lee curtis
kevin hart
jack black
edgar ramirez
jeanine
i mean car i mean i and i was there for
two months
i mean i did reservation dogs and then
i'm on sex in the city
the new sex in the city and then i'm
also i've done four episodes of that and
then i sold a show to abc wow and then i
have one more and then i have oh magnum
pi i'm doing magnum pi again you know i
mean three episodes this season and um
it's just been
incredible and it's like this is a good
i'm like 10 years ago
i could get nothing
i couldn't get my agents to call me back
i couldn't get an audition i couldn't
get anything weren't you on curb
yeah but like they'll be i would do curb
and then two years will go by and
nothing
you know and this time i think two
things happen number one
um
my podcasting
right
it completely helped me because it's
like every job that i've gotten from the
movie to everything were
because producers or somebody
was a tiger belly fan or a bad friends
fan right and number two um
no just that
i thought
it had nothing to do with it
no
no i don't know
but it's just like it just kind of all
[Music]
caught up you know what i mean and it
just feels
completely different
and i don't know what happened but um
am i happy i can't yeah i think i think
so
yeah are you going to stay in la for a
while yeah for
forever
i'm an la guy for are you
i love l.a i love la too
it is everything that i need those
[ __ ] idiots that moved to texas
those [ __ ] morons some of them were
coming back tim dillon i saw him the
other night he's like i'm moving back
october 1st it's like no [ __ ] they saw
that on the joey diaz podcast yeah they
got to come back well yeah there's
nothing out there i mean it's gonna be
fun for three years yeah la's the best
yeah you could have the it has the best
food if you could you know where to go
right
it's got you know the beaches the best
weather
the best weather you don't have to
[ __ ] scrape ice off your windshield
to go to work in the morning yeah it's a
little it's expensive i get it
but it's like um but also la has the
thing
that
the weed no this is weed i just kidding
but they have
just by
living here
magic can happen
i'll give you an example
i was
i was in a one time i was in
koreatown i was up at a korean
restaurant called
super jeep
and um i was eating with my girlfriend
and this korean guy comes up to me
what what'd you say the korean guy came
up to me okay would you guess that
i heard something no no a korean guy
came up to me yeah and he goes uh
hey dude
i'm eating i'm like what's up
hey i like the comedy
right it'll sound mexican yeah
hey bro like you know i like your comedy
i go thank you [ __ ] i direct her
and i go oh cool
right
because you want to do music videos
i go i love music videos and i don't
know what it was but it's like i gave
him my number
so a week later
the dude texted me tomorrow music video
if he got a response from you i'm gonna
be livid
what yeah did you respond right away no
no i did
because i he i think he texted me i have
made the video right
he and he said two words
eminem
and he goes dr dorae
and i go what
so he gave me the address i show up
next thing i know i'm in a [ __ ] van
right like a bus
with dr dre and marshall you know eminem
and i'm doing one of their music videos
right so you're in uh one of the videos
it's called
um we made you i think the song is
called is it out yet it was not this is
years ago this happened this is back
back in the day
and like
those are so many things like that
happen where i'm like somewhere
right and somebody goes hey you know i
mean this is in la
you know i mean i'm doing something like
i was back in the day when i you know so
what was the situation you were eating
and this guy worked at the restaurant no
he was just the guy that was eating
there uh okay he just walked right up to
me and he goes you know music video
that's basically all he said
he was the director of this [ __ ]
eminem video it was crazy and he knew
you from the podcast no you know this is
way before the podcast he knew me from
mad tv or whatever wow right but i'm
just saying that like things like that
happen where you're just kind of like
yeah i was at a kodak store because i
had one back in the day when you had to
just this is years ago
um you'd have to take these disposable
cameras right and then
i would
use 12 of them and then in six months
i'll go to a kodak store to get them
developed i was waiting in line in the
one in beverly center and seth rogen was
behind me in line
and he goes i saw you at the lab factory
can you be in my movie pineapple express
and i go all right yeah i mean like just
like little
things that happen just by being here
you know i mean so it's like i don't
want to move to austin
because like that doesn't happen like i
can do stand up here yeah you know
you become a very good stand-up by the
way thanks bro and i want to say
that rarely do i see somebody that
you know comes you know it you know i'm
an i'm a
organic stand-up i would i started it
started with it at when i was 23. open
mics i did the whole thing and so it's
like when i see like an actor
or you know an entertainer entertainer
like yourself
decide to do stand-up later in their
career whatever they i have to be honest
there is like a gut like reaction of
like come on you know i mean what the
[ __ ] i mean
but so it takes a while for me to go
to watch somebody and go
you know what
ethio did it because theo was theo
vaughn was you know
house rules yeah he was on some mtv show
right and then he started doing stand-up
and we were kind of like why is this guy
and then he became you're
very much like that where it's like a
guy that
you know you're from jackass and it's
like you did it and you put in the work
that's the thing
it's like
it's hard you know how hard it is stand
up
and when you're one of those guys that
like
is you're an actor and you do it once in
a while
right to make a quick buck or whatever
right it just doesn't um sit well with
me but when somebody
goes you know i know that this is a
completely different craft
and i'm going to put in the [ __ ] work
then i can gain a respect
because i'm sure you had some
suffering
when you started doing stand-up you're
sure how hard it was yeah yeah and
i also
um
was fortunate that i didn't realize how
bad it was
yeah
i was eating [ __ ] but i didn't really
know that
yeah yeah yeah i just took the last that
i got and the last that i got really put
wind in my sails right and kept me at it
um and uh
and and i also had
when i when i started doing it um i i
was
uh i'd mixed in stunts like every like
even if i did two shows friday two shows
saturday i'm still doing all those
stunts over and over and over and over
again wow wow and that and that kind of
helped me along but dude thank you so
much man i really do
because i remember even before you did
it though i would see you at the clubs
in the audience yeah right so it's like
you know i mean you're doing you're
studying as well like how does this work
i mean that that was when i got sober
i'm not going to bars i'm not going to
nightclubs anymore the only place that i
would go would be to the comedy club
because i had a reason to be there yeah
but that in that way also it's like okay
he's trying to like learn the thing yeah
but it's cool i think rap report does it
you know i mean i you know i i like
coming
i've heard good things about his stand
up i like piven as well you know he's
putting the work in though you know i
mean he goes up a lot
and when people go up like i just don't
like it when like you know
i want to name names but there have been
people that
did it and they just decided just to go
on the road
like they did went up twice
and all of a sudden because they have a
name they went on the road and then
with that hat what happens is then they
sell out
a big club
and they eat a dick
and then they stop doing it because it's
so brutal right that's not what you did
you kind of slowly got there i got on i
got to hitting the road
pretty quickly
you know
i i dove into it i started doing it all
all the time all the time
and uh and then i was presented with the
opportunity to get on the road when our
jackass 3d came out ah
so so i got into it pretty pretty
quickly wasn't it from a howard stern
interview yeah i went on howard to
promote jackass 3d and i was like howard
i'm doing stand-up every night and i
love it and i want to do it in new york
tonight
and i did it at the cellar that night
yeah how long did you do
like 10 minutes sat at the cellar like
whatever was it hard
seller can be a little intimidating i
mean yeah okay it was it's intimidating
it was even when i played the seller
it's like this is you know it's the
comedy store of new york i think it's
like that's deep history
everyone's a killer you know i but uh
you know but but whatever it is man i
always did take it seriously i always
did care about it and work hard
and and thank you man
it's uh do you have a new jackass coming
out right yeah but they've just pushed
the date from october to february but
you shot it already yeah
is it good it's [ __ ] great
nothing's ever gonna be our second
jackass movie but this smoked the third
jackass maybe yeah i can i'll be honest
with you can i um
you could say no but
i've always
liked you guys
huh and
is there
some sort of like if you have a
screening or something where i could get
invited to and so i can meet some
i want to i've always wanted to meet
johnny knoxville i did i would love to
be real i i feel like two words music
video
really
i would assume that there will be one
yeah and i would love for you to you're
gonna forget i i won't do it he's gonna
do it you're not gonna text back
[ __ ] you yesterday
[ __ ] you guys yesterday did you text me
yesterday you didn't get back to me the
time before [ __ ] out how fast pretty
quick
very quickly so is that a changed man or
what
i was stoked i was i was like i was
really and guess what who's here
you are
yeah
you know what like whenever whatever i
mean you are here for sure
to the minute right on time yeah
whenever changed man
you don't like my wings
yeah i like it dude
i have this little habit when i record
the intros for for my my podcast it's
called wild ride yeah and every episode
i say i give i give each episode an
adjective
like that but the last one i that i
recorded i said welcome to an
exhilarating world ride right and i
think that the the adjective for this
episode welcome to a controversial
wilderness why
because
well there's that yeah yeah there's
there's that guy there's we we
really don't me getting beat we really
delved into a
great deal of scandals yeah yeah yeah a
bunch of uh
you know we peeled back the
the curtain yeah
people love controversy yeah
i don't think it was controversial okay
good yeah i thought it was um being
honest yeah right yeah how we feel you
know it's like um
you feel it out like i don't have an
agenda when i come to this [ __ ] van
or this bus or whatever whatever it is
you know i
i just sat here and i go let's just see
what happens you know
but it's
bro let me ask you something what um
let me ask you something
do you have a girlfriend no right when's
the last time you had a girlfriend a
couple years ago man was that a
nightmare
but do you do you see girls now
uh i haven't as of lately just because
we've been working a lot
but
he [ __ ]
right let me ask you something if you
and i were not i always asked this if
you and i were shipwrecked on a island
yeah
right
and it's a small island it's maybe like
a half mile around just you and i
in the center of the island are like
a little jungle area
right maybe a little hill right but
around it's still like a lot of beaches
really blue right two months
two months what
finish your question no no
what were you answering what were your
answering how long would it take for us
to bone
two months
yeah wow i was gonna say year year
yeah yeah yeah because i'm not gay
yeah i think two months is like because
in the beginning we're like we got to
build a shelter
you and i
right we got to figure it out you'd be
like winking at me and like touching me
you're like blowing on me and i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know
i'll do the wings and i'll do the you
know whatever right but like you know
don't mean we haven't fresh water we're
sleeping butt to butt at night yeah yeah
because it gets cold at night yeah yeah
i mean
how did i know you were going there with
that question
is that what you're going to ask yeah
yeah yeah i'll be giving off some
serious andy dick vibes yeah yeah
i feel like if you and i weren't a
violin it would take 20 years
[Laughter]
three days
if i don't think so i don't think so i
don't think so yeah i think a couple of
years you and i are about to because
we're friends
six minutes
no he'd be someone i kill
why
why'd you and then because you don't
like carnies kill me and then [ __ ] a
weird vibe about him you know what i
mean i'd probably kill him all right
yeah
okay no i would not kill you but um so
you say you said two months
i mean realistically probably like
a year that realistically right yeah but
why would you let me ask you this i know
why would we even have to go there
because we're sick in the head i feel
like and it's like on the subject of
winking
yeah ian edwards had the best bit about
this
but where he he was like uh
you know he he said
he was talking about like people who are
ugly and you're giving an example it'd
be like uh
like the the woman who murdered selena
yeah and that like you automatically get
an image of you and you're like ah
that's so funny because like yeah
he's like
it's it was it
i'm confusing bits because he said
whenever people have two different races
have a child that that that child is
going to be gorgeous yeah even if the if
it's the woman who murdered selena and
then he had another example all right i
think it
it is a great bit yeah yeah yeah it's a
great bit but but then someone maybe
i just remember there being a bit about
someone be like be like you know what
like i i i'm not gay i can tell you
right now that i like uh if you lock me
up with the woman who murdered selena
like uh
like i'm gonna reach a point where it's
like yeah you know like i need some
[ __ ] yeah yeah but like at no point if
you lock me up with brad pitt is that
gonna happen
someone had this great comedy bit like
that yeah yeah
no brad pitt yes i would yeah i'd [ __ ]
brad pitt right away i'll do it now yeah
yeah yeah yeah i would drive myself
right now i would do it for the story
yeah i saw him
before we confirmed it's an island even
like
maybe it's a peninsula maybe there's
like people it's like no all right right
we land and i and i see a resort we got
a talent yeah yeah
we're on a [ __ ] island he's like are
you sure yeah yeah and the four seasons
like you know man yeah it's like mile
away we're gonna die yeah when it dies
suck my dad
right he's like really yeah 69.
and we're on the beach and then like
tourists walk by
well we're 69.69
[Music]
yeah what do you think
i do what uh whatever the show is
yeah yeah isn't this do you think it's
good i i i sure i like it
paul always this is my
you know because i'll always assume like
i was awful there's been and then pauses
now it's good now it's like okay good i
think it was great okay
i love this all right i have to tell you
a story
all right after we turn this off oh okay
so how do we end it how do we end it
well i do but i'm going to listen to a
private story now i said thank you bob
you turned it off though big bob thank
you thank you for having me on yeah
we're cut go ahead and tell the story
did i tell you or did i tell you that
that episode was loaded with uh highly
controversial topics man
um i love bobby lee
i also love you for sticking around to
the very end
what can i tell you man um as you're
watching this it will be about 24 hours
after i'm talking to you right now
i'll be in texas
surfing at a wave pool in waco getting
ready to
kill it at my first big theater show
and wendy will be with me
as well
paul briskey
yeah
is your album yet out paul no it comes
out september 16th so paul's album comes
out september 16th and if you don't get
it on that day then you're not a real
fan
[ __ ] you